conservatives believe in transparency in
government when they make things a
secret like where they're buying these
drugs you have to ask yourselves
ourselves what are they trying to hide
when you talk about the transparency
issues where they're making these secret
drug combinations it has nothing to do
with national security but it's being
paid for with taxpayer funds so we
deserve and have the right to know where
that money is going so whenever I look
at any program to try to decide whether
or not it's conservative I give it what
I call the conservative litmus test I
ask myself is it constitutional is it
pro life is it fiscally responsible and
is a representative of a limited
government the death penalty is easily
inconsistent with at least three of
those it's not pro-life it's not
physically responsible and it sure is
not limited government I've had some
conversations with fellow conservatives
about this and one of them actually
supported the death penalty he told me
that if we keep continuing to have these
botched executions that take hours and
obvious you're not working properly that
he's going to have to stop supporting
the death billing because that's not
what he wants to see government involved
in one of the criticisms that i often
get from people who support the death
penalty they try to talk about some of
these horrific crimes where it seems
obvious that the offender is guilty so
they believe that we we have the duty to
execute them but in the end i try to
remind them that if you want to execute
the real guilty the real bad people you
have to have a system in place and
because humans and governments are
fallible some innocent people are going
to get caught up in the mix so my
question is if you want to be able to
execute a few bad people how many
innocent people are you willing to
execute because collateral damage will
come along with that and so far nobody's
been able to answer that oftentimes the
other criticism is well hopefully this
deters murder for every 100 murders
about one of those results in a death
sentence less than that one actually
gets executed and that happens 10 20 30
40 years later do you think that goes
through anyone's head before they commit
a heinous act
think so
you